>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Mari Nakahara: Good
afternoon, everybody.
On behalf of the Prints and
Photographs Division of the Library
of Congress and its Center
for Architecture, Design,
and Engineering, it's my great
pleasure to welcome you all
to today's lecture, "Tracking
Time: Twin Towers and Motor City,"
by the distinguished American
photographer and documentarian,
Camilo Jose Vergara,
followed by a book signing
of his newly published book,
Detroit Is No Dry Bones.
My name is Mari Nakahara.
I am a curator of architecture,
design, and engineering at the P
and P we call -- Prints
and Photographs Division.
I have been in this position for
the last one year and nine months.
In comparison with my predecessor,
[inaudible] -- he's there --
his career is, was 40
years, and he retired April.
I am still a baby.
I'm still trying to learn
many things of the Prints
and Photographs Division collection,
especially related to architecture,
design, and engineering,
which actually pertains
to about four million items.
In my early stage of the learning,
Mr. Vergara's photographs
caught my eye.
Having a background as
an architecture historian
and as a former resident
of New York City,
I have been paying attention
to changes in the city.
When I visited Detroit,
the hometown of my husband,
in 2007 for the first time,
I was very much fascinated
by the buildings in that city.
Beautiful Art Deco buildings,
and then I couldn't find
out why the city actually
deteriorated that much.
Then I got so much interested in
knowing the history of that city.
Mr. Vergara's photography resonated
with these personal curiosities.
This summer, when the library
received from Mr. Vergara a series
of World Trade Center photographs,
I actually caught my breath
for a moment, recalling the time
and the difficulties that I went
through in New York City in 2001
as a new immigrant to this country.
That became a trigger for
me to host today's event.
This is the first event,
lecture event which I coordinated
as a curator for architecture,
design, and engineering.
Let me introduce Camilo
a little bit.
>> Sorry, I'm having trouble--
[ Inaudible ]
[ Laughter ]
>> Mari Nakahara: I hope I don't
have any connection trouble.
[laughs] Camilo Jose Vergara
was born in Chile in 1949
and is a formally trained
sociologist and writer as well
as one of the top documentary
photographers working today.
His acclaimed books
include Silent Cities:
The Evolution of the
American Cemetery in 1989;
New American Ghetto in 1995;
American Ruins in 1999;
Twin Towers Remembered, 2001;
Unexpected Chicagoland published
in 2001; Subway Memories in 2004;
How the Other Half Worships in 2005;
Harlem: The Unmarking, Unmaking --
I'm sorry -- of a Ghetto in 2013;
and Detroit Is No Dry
Bones, published this year,
which is available for
purchase after this lecture.
The website which you are
seeing here, Invincible Cities,
has made his work better known
through a special map-based
interface.
I played around a little bit.
I strongly suggest you do the same.
It's really interesting.
Chronological order.
The cities and the locations,
you can see how the
city has been changing.
A MacArthur Fellow Genius Award
in 2002 recognized the exceptional
stature of Vergara's work.
In 2013, Vergara became
the first photographer
to receive the president
National Humanities Medal.
In 2013, Vergara selected the
Library of Congress, thanks to him,
to be the permanent home for
his photographic archive.
Previous acquisition of
Vergara's work were the series
of Silent Cities, which
is documenting cemeteries
across the United States
between 1976 and 1989.
And Twin Towers Remembered, which
is recording that World Trade Center
in New York City between
1970 and in 2001.
As of today, approximately 8000
photographs have been transferred
to the library, and the full
archive is expected to offer
about 10,000 images spanning
the 1970's through the 2010's.
Before introducing Camilo,
please note that this event is
being videotaped for the broadcast
on the library's website
and the other media.
We encourage you in the
audience to ask questions
and offer comments during the
question and answer period.
But please realize that in
participating in the Q&A period,
you'll be consenting to the
library possibly producing
and transmitting your remarks.
Finally, please join me in
welcoming Camilo Jose Vergara.
[ Applause ]
>> Camilo Vergara: Thank
you very much, Mari.
Couple of things.
She made me five years younger,
so that, very grateful for that.
[laughter]
>> Mari Nakahara: So you can just--
>> Camilo Vergara: Yes.
I'm also very happy
to see Helena here,
and to see Floyd [assumed
spelling], and certainly Mari
and Phil [assumed spelling] that's,
that are doing this wonderful work
putting this exhibition together,
this collection together.
And every time I come here,
I find this place friendlier
and friendlier.
I just, it just, it's amazing when
you start doing photography all
over the country and start
going to different places
to present your work, after you
go back, and back, and back,
you just feel at home
in the different places,
and it's just a wonderful feeling.
So I want to start with the
section from Detroit here,
then show a few pictures of
the World Trade Center series,
and somewhere along the line,
I will explain how the title
came about that you will see.
So Detroit Is No Dry Bones.
My first encounter with the city of
Detroit was stepping into a feeling
of unbelief, and it
was unbelief because,
not that I hadn't seen skyscrapers
before because I had been
to Chicago, and I had seen them
there, and I had seen briefly
in New York, but I had never
seen an abandoned skyscraper.
And I had never seen 12
abandoned skyscrapers.
[laughs] You know, that
was, what's going on here?
And, you know, when I asked that
question, I'd take a picture
because I'm kind of slow
in figuring out things,
so I figure I'd take a picture,
and then I'll take another picture,
and then slowly, you begin to
maybe not figure out how all
of this came about, but just
have some sense of direction
of what is happening between the
time you first became acquainted
with it and then the time sort
of you lived off, you know.
That you, you're through.
You end. I just, I
would look at buildings.
This is the United Artists Building.
The first photograph was a
photograph that was taken
from the hotel that was
at the, at that time,
was a Salvation Army
building called Harbor Light.
And it was taken in '91.
That's about 25 years ago.
Building doesn't exist anymore, but
I sort of almost saw that I wanted
to do that, retake that picture
year after year after year,
and then the building
was knocked off.
And it was, before
that was cinder block,
so I had to stop, like,
at 2002 or '03.
And since then, this whole area
has been revitalized and rebuilt.
The whole empty front, you know.
It's not, it's still empty, but
in, within a couple of years,
all of that's going to,
the picture is going
to be a completely different one.
Some of the abandoned
buildings, even this one,
may be rehabilitated someday.
You would find odd things.
So I decided that one of my
jobs was to sort of keep track
of things that get left out.
So like this man, who
was the caretaker
of a 32-story skyscraper called
the Broderick Building in Detroit,
and that building, you can see
this, we're on the roof there.
And he told me at one
time, you know, we were 15.
There were 15 people that maintained
this building, and at this point,
must've been around '91, '92.
He was the only one, and
he could, he was not all
that energetic, you
know, at that time.
So, but every time I went to
Detroit, I would find him,
and we would go to the roof, or we'd
stop in different floors and look
around at this collection.
It was this large skyscraper that
you can see in the first picture
that had been left behind.
People had just left, and there
were lawyers' office, you know,
where all the archives were
full with stories of divorces,
and dentists' office that had the
state of the mouth of thousands
of people because there
were many dentists' office.
And they had a collection of
equipment, that was ten years old
or 20 years old, you
know, that was rusting.
And I found that extremely
interesting.
There was also city offices
in some of these buildings
and even records, you know.
The parole office could
be in a building,
and then you have all these
parole records left behind.
There was a section of Detroit.
It was like the first wealthy
section that was called Brush Park.
And it was so derelict.
This is in 1987, and I just
thought there's nothing
that could happen here but this,
it's just going to return to nature.
It was a house that was, a mansion
that was built by a lumber baron.
Detroit was in a strategic
place, so when the lumber came
from upper Wisconsin, you
know, through the lake,
it would come to Detroit, and
that's what got Detroit started
in developing a carriage industry.
First, there were wagons, you
know, and then they, railroad,
into the railroads, and
finally, into cars, so.
So here, we're going to see
the evolution of this place.
This is '91, and you can see
the weeds get even bigger.
You can also see, and
here it's about 2000.
And that's today.
And I think the incredible thing
is just not only shows the building
coming back, it shows how so
much of the, what was built
around it has disappeared,
is not there anymore.
And it shows a blonde woman here.
So you can fill in the rest.
I mean, they used to be first
an area of rooming houses.
I mean, first an area of
very wealthy people, then it,
they became rooming houses,
and the wealthy people went
to other neighborhoods
with larger houses.
Then it was a place for derelicts,
and people who, homeless people,
and the few people that
sort of hang onto it.
And then it's sort of coming back
again as a kind of middle-class,
and in some cases,
upper-class neighborhood.
Well, that one didn't
have the same look.
This one, for those of you who've
seen Beverly Hill Cops, number,
the cop number one
that was shot in 1984.
This, you'll see this at the
beginning of the picture.
Well, that's there no more.
New buildings were built there.
I have the picture.
I'm not showing it here now because
they are, compared to this, I mean,
these were beautiful
buildings that have been lost.
Again, if you get far from the
downtown and you go, in this case,
to the East Side of Detroit,
you see there is a church,
and then the churches would organize
these sort of sales of used clothes.
And here it's all laid
out, you know,
and you can imagine all the coats.
There's hundreds of coats and
those two women selling it.
And I thought of going back and
see what that looked like today.
I called the church too.
I wanted to know, I was
very surprised to know,
find out that they actually
didn't even remember the name
of the two women there.
You know, so that's what
it looks like today.
This is another set of
two pictures separated
by about the same number
of years, over 20 years.
This is the first one.
Street, it's near Eastern Market
for those of you who know Detroit.
It's in the East Side too.
And what you see here,
one of my great interests,
it's what happens in between.
It's the efforts.
I mean, those places didn't
just sit there and decay,
but there were efforts
from the city to do things.
There were efforts from people
who lived there to do things.
And I thought it was important
to keep track of those things,
not just wait until the
whole place was level.
And so a new population,
new buildings,
new everything came about.
So here you can see
that at one point,
the city may have put
planters and new trees.
You see the planters there.
It was big supermarket here.
And this is basically
what it looks like today,
but you still can see
the planters, you know.
So you can do, like, a kind
of an archaeology of places.
This is the Packard Plant,
which is probably the largest
of the car plants there, which is,
at one point during World War II,
they built airplane engines there.
They built Rolls-Royce
engines for --
lots of discoveries were
made there, advances.
One of them was soundproofing
buildings because they had
to test these aircraft engines,
which, you know, of course,
they would render you
deaf in no time.
So they had, they did a
lot of insulation also
because of the temperatures rose
so much, they had special ways
to ventilate it and
air condition it.
Again, it was, the core of the
factory was built by Albert Kahn,
who was a great Detroit architect.
So here you have it in '91.
And at that time, the city
even thought that buildings
like this could be recovered,
reclaimed, made into something else.
So the idea here, we
had one industry
that at one time employed
30,000, 35,000 people.
We could have 200, you
know, small shops here,
and each one of them
would employ 100.
And then we'll be in business.
It actually didn't happen
that way, but it was sort
of interesting to see
what would come.
And, you know, there would
be a laundry [phonetic].
There would be a place
that would have used shoes.
There'll be a place
that had cardboard.
Another place where they
took cars to take apart.
You know, stolen cars.
And then they, you can see the
building sort of crumpled part
by part, and at this point --
and this is I think this year --
it was taken over by some
Spanish entrepreneur that wants
to make it, bring it back.
So he puts the name there.
I don't know where he went, to
Kinko's, and made this sign.
[laughs] So here is the Packard
sign, which it's, it was fancy
and substantial at one point.
And then he put a picture here
that has old Packard cars.
So that's the Packard plant.
There were other plants like
that, and this is one of them.
It's a, it's made airplane
-- I mean, not airplane --
car engines, automobile engines,
and there is the name, Continental.
So they continue buildings like this
as the other building
continued to have a life.
They have a life in the internet
because you have kids
actually go there --
and I don't know why they do this
-- they skateboard on the roof
and they do things that you think
they're all going to get killed,
and they, you see those,
and you too [phonetic].
Also, they go with drones, you
know, so that they fly the drones,
and the drones show you all
the crevices of the building,
which is sort of fascinating
to watch.
I was just, I like what's happening
to the parking lot there,
the way it's cracking.
And it looked like almost
like the surface of the Moon.
There were buildings.
This is part of the ruins of
Detroit, and what attracted me
to that -- it was a very, very
exciting type of ruins to me,
and those were the ruins of the
buildings that, in my childhood,
in some little town
in Chile, you know,
I would look at pictures of them.
But they were like the buildings
that would be built
in Mars, you know.
I thought that was the future.
That was, you know, and
I believe in the future.
I thought the future was going
to be wonderful and there'd be,
going to be buildings like this.
But I never thought that I was
going to face them as ruins.
So this, buildings like this, and
I think there's another one here.
Well, this is a little earlier.
But they were built,
this was built before.
The one before was built
right after the World War II
when architects spent some
time without building too much
because it was, the war was there.
So they kept dreaming of, you
know, this exciting, new city,
this new civilization that was going
to be built after the war was over.
This, on the other
hand, is an old diner --
one of many that were built,
like, right around the time
of the Depression, right
before the Depression.
There would, I think the company
that built them was
based in Wisconsin.
I don't know what the name
of it was, but they built
like 30 of them in Detroit.
I mean, Detroit was a boom town.
They needed cheap places to eat.
And then this is like I'm
encountering this building, like,
in its last night almost, you know,
because then I started going back,
and it's now abandoned, but you
can see there it looks almost
like there is a congregation
of ghosts
that are having coffee
and burgers there.
Except that, they're invisible.
But the light means that there is
still some life in the building.
Again, there are other
buildings that get this new life
in different ways, you know.
It's that at one point, like with
the building I showed you before,
you know, where Eddie Murphy
paraded in front of it in 1984,
this made 8 Mile, the movie 8 Mile,
and you can see Eminem pass by
and with some kind of a water
gun, or something, or paint gun.
They just shoot at the steer.
So before they did the,
they shot that scene,
the designers for the
movie repainted the steer.
If you go near the Rouge Plant,
which is on the West Side
of Detroit, you see scenes
like this, which are,
to me, were extraordinary.
I just thought that
[laughs] that'd be a house
where they wouldn't go
trick-or-treating to.
[ Laughter ]
Then there was this development
that I captured in Camden,
and Chicago, and other cities.
And that's, you know, you have a
building that has two families,
and then one side is occupied
and the other side is abandoned.
And both of them continue
their life,
their movement into the future.
And I'm very interested in
seeing what's going to happen.
So you can see the one that's
occupied put his fence on, and,
you know, sort of protecting itself.
Except that the problem is
that if somebody squats here
and builds a fire to
stay warm in the winter,
the whole things can burn.
Here you see, oh, another
example of one of those pairs.
It's not that the house that is
occupied is in very good shape,
but it's certainly
better than the other one.
And here it's like extreme
case of someone that's holding
out between two abandoned houses
and puts the American flag,
and it's certainly making an effort
to stay there and preserve
the house.
I thought that those stories were
important, that those stories need
to be told, and that
also, they are stories
that are very easy to
ignore or not to see.
Then I look at the
landmarks of Detroit,
of which there are
many, and very striking.
This is a conservatory where there
is a great collection of orchids,
and it's in an island
that's called Belle Isle,
which is a very beautiful place.
I, I'm not sure, but I think
Albert Kahn designed that.
Maybe Floyd knows.
And this is the Fisher Mansion, and
there are several Fisher Mansions.
Fisher was a very wealthy man,
very wealthy family from Detroit
that did the carriages for the cars.
So they would do tens
of millions of them.
So you can imagine what
a big thing that was.
And they, you know, houses
like this were built by them.
And this is the decoration
of one of them.
It's in an area called
Boston-Edison.
Then again, what the, what I realize
this, in this Detroit, and I'll get,
later on, I'll get into
gentrification and so on.
And the tremendous contrast
between the people who were there,
and live there, and stay there,
and their values, and so on --
I remember reading
somewhere the only super,
Jesus is the only superstar.
And I thought, I mean, everywhere
you go, there is Christianity.
There's a church.
There is something or other.
You look at the kids that are
coming in, and they're, you know,
opening up bakeries, and bars, and
restaurants, and shops, and so on.
And it's a very, very
different thing.
You don't see any reference
to this other life of Detroit
where Christianity is important.
As you can see, it gets
too hot in the summer,
so you bring your church
out [phonetic].
Plus, it's also a way to pick
up, you offer people some food.
They sit. They listen to you.
Maybe they'll become
members of the church.
Then this sort of thing,
which builds, this sort of,
it's a very, very strange thing.
It sort of creates an
aura of authenticity
around the city of Detroit.
So Detroit, it's seen
by many people.
You know, this is the real thing.
This is the place because
you see things like this.
I mean, you see the hand.
You see people do it by hand.
People put their things that are not
mediated and not going to be found
in hundreds of other places.
Everything, you know, at
least in this place is kind
of unique, one of its kind.
Oh, like that, you know.
So Christ, why not put him in
the Upper Peninsula, you know?
Walking in Northern Michigan.
Or if you have an abandoned
building, you know,
why don't you put stories
from, you know,
the life of Christ or something?
And then there are these other quite
sophisticated signs that you see.
And there is no place for
them to go, so in some sense,
I felt that it was my job to go
there and photograph, you know,
the ones that I saw,
and put them up,
and make sure that people knew them.
Then this, there is this
other difference here.
I mean, this need to
construct a history,
to tell a history, you know.
We begin with the Egyptians,
so here it's the Egyptians.
You know, and then
here it comes Mandela,
and slavery gets put in the middle.
And it keeps moving to the right,
and it ends up with Coleman Young,
which was a very influential
mayor of Detroit.
And under his, he being the mayor,
they built the Renaissance Center,
which is the building
that you see here.
And also, the People Mover.
Now, in the sort of gentrifier
version or their, you know,
the other version of Detroit, none
of those two things would appear
because they are consider
as huge boondoggles --
you know, things that fail,
that just waste of money.
But for their black population,
because they were doing,
they were built and put there at
a time when there was a, the city,
there was black control of the city,
and the city was sort of a center
of what you call Black America.
So that's a detail
from that picture.
There is something really very
powerful about this, you know.
Just you see all these faces
here, and you see it fading out.
I mean, certainly didn't look like
this when it was first painted.
Then the idea that you have,
this idea that you have
to tell your history.
I mean, no gentrifier coming to
Detroit says, look, you know, my,
here is my grandpa, you know.
He came from Italy and he
brought, he used to cook pasta,
or he had, we have Garibaldi here.
Maybe the old immigrants do that.
They used to do that, of course,
because they had statures
[inaudible].
But today, this urgency, this
need is felt in graphics like this
where you see the Renaissance Center
on top, you see the American flag,
"The Fist" of Joe Louis's fist here.
And then you see here, you see
Malcolm X, King, and Coleman Young,
and the two black artists that
in the, lifted their fists
in the Olympics in Mexico City.
So that is a statement.
And I would go to sort
of out of the way place,
really out of the way place.
If you want to know where
this is, you know, you just,
it'd be quite hard
to find by chance.
But to me, there were
statements that needed
to be preserved, as well as this.
I think this is wonderful.
It's on the cover of the book,
on the back cover of the book.
This is a view of Mahalia Jackson.
And I doubt that you could get, you
know, sort of a better portrait,
you know, not -- it's,
of course, not there.
It disappeared a long time ago.
But I'm glad I have a picture of it.
Then there is all this kind
of naïve signage paintings
that people put for purposes.
I mean, they give dance
classes here in this place.
Here is a place that fixes cars,
and they hired a homeless man.
It says, look, we got
some paint here.
Why don't you do something?
He said he was an artist, so he
did the history of transportation.
[laughter] You know, which for
Detroit is just what you need.
And how do you leave in a city with,
you know, you have a daycare center.
All of your kids are black.
Snow White happens to be Caucasian.
So how do you deal with that?
Well, you paint her brown, or you
paint her green, or you paint her,
you know, it's always a color.
So you go there and you ask
these questions, you know.
[inaudible] try to find out if
this has anything to do with race.
And they tell you, no, it doesn't
have anything to do with race.
It just, you know, kids like this
because it reminds
him of chocolates.
[ Laughter ]
They are the inventions that people
make to sort of cope with the fact
that there are over 3000
bus stops in Chicago
that have nowhere you can sit and
wait for the bus, you know, so you,
in here, you may get rained
over, but you still have a place
that you can sit on, that
somebody came up with that.
And I thought that if I was
writing something about inventions,
I would love to write a story of who
thought this up, and went looking
for the tires, and found that, I
mean, of course, then the city finds
out that there is this, and
they feel ashamed of it,
and they dismantle it, so this
thing only lived for a few weeks.
But to me, it's, it was, it's one
of the most important
pictures in my Detroit series.
What's behind is an
old police station.
Now, there are other
immigrants that come to Detroit.
Some of them are immigrants.
Some of them are children
of immigrants,
and they're Greeks and Albanians.
And their specialty,
it's to buy some
of the failed Kentucky Fried
Chickens, and McDonald's, and,
you know, all those
big franchises that go,
try to make a go and can't do it.
So they built it, and then they put
like a hat on top of it that's made
out of a material called Dryvit.
And you can make almost
anything you want with it.
You can build the Parthenon
if you want with Dryvit.
Won't last very long, and
if a car hits it, you know,
you'll have it all coming down.
But Detroit has the most
extraordinary examples
of this type of, if you want to
call it architecture or design,
is all over the United States, but
Detroit, it excels in doing it.
This is a, you can
still see the lights
from the original White Castles.
You see those.
Then Detroit, because it got so,
it began to get so much attention,
you know, and the eyes
of the world were there,
and you could do something
on the streets of Detroit,
and it was better than
having something
in a gallery, in an art gallery.
So then this works in two ways.
First of all, these are students
that did a thesis is building.
There were students at a place
called Cranbrook Academy,
which is in very wealthy suburbs
of Detroit, north of Detroit.
Bloomfield Hills, I
think it's called.
And so they built this
house for about $60,000.
A family lived there
about six months,
and then it flopped
and became abandoned.
And then, of course,
the taggers come along.
So this is GASM, you know, tag.
All over Detroit is his tag.
And then, of course, there was
another, there was a local artist
that would put dots in
abandoned buildings,
and his name is [inaudible].
So [inaudible] put the dot there.
So a few years passed by.
Some development came
out of the center,
and this is not far from the center.
And it's in, like, the largest,
one of the largest
empty lots in Detroit.
So they figured that's what
it's going to be rebuilt next.
So somebody started an Airbnb
there and redecorated the house
by inviting a muralist from
Brooklyn that has some name,
and I guess it's doing some
castles and fantasy in that place.
This is recent.
It's like a year old.
You can see the size
of the lot around it.
It's probably going to
be all built very soon.
But in the meanwhile, you can have
your honeymoon there if you want to.
[laughter] You, and you get
that view there, and so,
I mean, if you're brave enough.
So this is another.
It's a homage to a graffiti artist
from Houston, Texas called NEKST
who put his name all over the place.
He's all over Philadelphia.
He's in Houston and so on.
And he happened to die.
So there is a way in which this
artist that they, at least him,
and you can see some of
their, they are on the web.
They have little films about, you
know, when they go out tagging.
And, you know, here he's
opening a bottle of champagne.
Now, the problem was that he
was using that menacing knife
to open the bottle of champagne, and
what that, the result of that was
that a city inspector drove by and
he says, "This is inciting crime."
So then the lady that owned
the building hired somebody,
and that's what [laughter]
it looks like today.
And, well, the building, the mural
continues to be very popular,
but for the wrong reason.
People go and see what happened
to the masterpiece, you know.
And here we come to,
"Detroit is no dry bones."
So what happens, the condition of
Detroit becomes famous all over,
so there are four designers
from Holland that come
to Detroit with a great idea.
What if we convince ministers,
pastors to change the word,
put the word "Detroit" wherever
they put the word "God"?
So, of course, the
project didn't do very well
because the pastor didn't want
anything to do with such an idea.
But they went to this church, and
the minister was having a sermon
that day, and it was
about God is no dry bones.
So then, well, you know, that was
their chance to put "Detroit."
So they put "Detroit."
So four white women from, well,
of course, from Holland did
that very neat writing and
very neat sign right there.
And it kind of, to me, it
brought together, you know,
sort of black culture, a city
that is falling apart and decaying
in many parts while at the same time
is resurging, and the, and this,
you know, this attention that
it's getting and the fact
that people would come as far away
as Rotterdam or some city like that
to do a sign the way you see it.
Again, of course, Detroit
got Banksy and they --
I'm getting close to the end?
Oh, there's probably two or three.
Okay. We'll have a problem
with the Trade Center, then.
How much of that one?
Okay.
>> Fifteen.
>> Camilo Vergara: Okay.
Okay, so the story here is
it's, this is another one
of those wonderful buildings that
were built after World War II
and designed after World
War II, and they were like,
this is what the future
is going to be like.
So it's there, and it's, you know,
the sign is, it's still standing.
And then what happened is that
Banksy happened in Detroit.
So he goes and he find this
to be a wonderful place
to do a piece of his work.
So he puts it there, and
within a couple days,
the whole wall has disappeared.
So now there's a big hole in there.
I mean, I want to give you a sense
of there are things that I generated
from the inside, like all those
religious images that I showed you
at the beginning or
the idea of history.
And then there is another type
of religious images, and that,
those are generated by people
from a church in Indiana
or people in a church in Illinois.
They say, we need to do
some good in the world,
so why not go into
Detroit and do something?
So they see abandoned buildings and
then they want to beautify them,
to make them more attractive.
So this is like a church from
Indiana or Illinois that comes
to Detroit and, you know, one
of the leaders is an artist.
And then they get some of the
local kids to collaborate.
And they paint these abandoned
buildings, and, you know,
one of them is religious.
The other one is ice cream.
But there are, you know,
these are the product
of a very different culture
and they are the product
of this tremendous
attention in Detroit.
Then there are volunteers
that come, you know.
They say volunteers that work for
Starbucks, or work for Ford Motor,
or work for Google,
or some other place.
They say, we want, they
give them a day to go
to Detroit or two days, you know.
So they get, and then they
try to create a little park.
And then there are the gentrifiers
that do try to recreate something
that it's, like, has a flavor
of what Old Detroit was,
but as a friend of mine says
-- he grew up in Detroit --
there was nothing like
this in Old Detroit.
Building that was a factory,
then it was an art gallery,
and now it's a bakery, which is,
which combines writing by hand,
seats that are taken from
abandoned schools in Detroit,
little architecture
details that were found,
and then attracts a group of people
that is a very mixed
group of people.
And, of course, there's a
couple taking a selfie there.
[laughs] You know, here you have an
old white bread [phonetic] building,
and there's a casino
that was built using
that building rather
than demolishing it.
And this is an image of the
Old Detroit, of the Detroit
of prosperity, of the
Detroit of money,
of the Detroit that,
of the '20's, you know.
You see they're putting the
money into the vaults there.
And the Detroit that was white too.
So here it's the designer
is a designer
that did a lot of work in Detroit.
His name was Corrado Parducci.
So black artists from the area
react and they say, this is,
that stuff is not ours, you know.
Here is ours.
Rosa Parks lived here, so Rosa
Parks replaces some of the other,
or it's placed there, you
know, as being the right image,
the right portrait to put there.
And that's Motown.
It's the, you can help yourself
to some postcards I have here
of the same postcard, and, yeah,
right, that entrance, which had,
you know, it's quite a small museum
but well attended and very popular.
Then there is a local folk artist
that has her view of Detroit
where the local funeral
home becomes as big
as the General Motors
World Headquarters,
the old one that's
right there in the back.
So it's, like, similar to what
we saw with Snow White is that,
you know, you can't, you have
to play around with the symbols
to just arrange them
in a different way.
Detroit was, and it, it's
a very spread-out city.
It's 139 square miles.
It's, it reached at one point
almost two million people,
and now it has a little
under 700,000.
So there is a lot of land,
and people cultivate
that and grow crops.
So it's this man, it's
a picture from '87.
And this is my last
picture for Detroit.
I don't know if we have time
to go into the Trade Center.
>> Very quickly.
>> Camilo Vergara: What?
Very quickly?
Okay.
>> Very quickly.
>> Camilo Vergara: So this is like
the symbol, a symbol of Detroit.
A very important train station.
Brought the president of the
United States for the inauguration.
I believe it was 1913.
And many people went to, you
know, service the war and so on,
you know, from that train station.
Got hundreds of trains every day.
It's been abandoned for
a while, so, any case.
So the Twin Towers,
it's a simple thing.
It's just, I first became
interested, you know,
because I was up on the projects.
I would photographs
from the projects.
I wanted to get an air view.
I didn't have money for a
helicopter or anything like that.
So I would go to the public housing
projects and photograph from there.
So here you can see New York
from about 1994 I think.
And this is 2001.
So what you see in 2001, there
is no World Trade Center.
And that's like, you
know, a few months ago.
But what this showed, it showed
big areas in the foreground,
so you could see how the
whole city was changing.
At the beginning, I was just
attracted to that because, you know,
it was, tallest building in my
town was three stories high,
and I wanted to know what one that,
say, 112 stories would be like.
I also had, like, an
attitude, you know,
so you've, you are in your 20s.
You feel, you know,
you are being left out.
Nobody cares about, and so you
figure, well, you too, you know.
You may be building the
tallest building in the world,
but there it's a homeless person
sleeping right in front of it.
So all of this at the old piers in
Jersey, and they have disappeared.
This is the beginning
when it was built.
And this is like the New
York of the French connection
that doesn't exist
anymore, which you can,
it was in a state of disintegration.
So much of it, you know, that
part of it, part of the impulse
to photograph it was that, you know,
it wasn't going to be there anymore.
And the irony here didn't scathe
me that this was Liberty Drive,
and then when the building went up,
the new building was
called the Freedom Tower.
So I took the pictures that
every tourist would take.
So this is from the Manhattan
Bridge, and from that very angle,
like, if you go there today,
they'd say, chain-link fence.
But there is a hole where
you can put your camera
and you can take this picture.
The only difference is that I kept
taking the picture every year.
So this is 79.
That's the day of September 11th.
And that's, like, a
few months later.
This is, like, 2005/2006.
And that's 2010, you know.
And then you begin to see
other buildings going up.
And you begin to see a
very different skyline.
There is the new what they call
them One World Trade Center.
That's at night.
And that's like the way
it is today, more or less.
And that's going to
continue changing.
I mean, it's basically, it's
a very, very different skyline
from what we saw many years ago.
And I'll go quickly
through the other series.
This I like very much because it
shows the church, the chapels,
St. Paul's Chapel that is
from the 1750's, more or less.
And it's kind of there, and
it stays put, and everything
around it kind of disappears.
You know, here is the Trade
Center goes, and new, you know,
some new building goes there.
And then the new One World Trade
Center is starting to go up.
And there it's completed.
So this is my presentation.
I thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Mari Nakahara: Thank
you very much, Camilo.
We would like to take a couple
questions if you have any.
We have five minutes.
Reese [phonetic].
>> [inaudible] apartment buildings?
Because what happens
if it's a high-rise
or garden apartment building and
one of the tenants abandons it?
Then the whole building
disintegrates?
You kind of showed duplexes,
but I wonder if it's a big
building, how can you do it?
>> Camilo Vergara: Well,
there are several pictures
of some big apartment
buildings from Detroit.
There were some quite
beautiful buildings
and some very large
apartment buildings.
And it's sort of a slow process,
you know, the disintegration
of an apartment building.
It's not, it doesn't
happen overnight.
I mean, sometimes a big fire is,
you know, it just takes care of it.
I mean, if the roof goes,
there you are, you know.
So it's, but I do, I follow
many apartment buildings.
Yeah. So go ahead.
>> Yes. I'm from Detroit,
although I left there in '72,
but I still go back to
visit my mother there.
She'll be 91 next month.
>> Camilo Vergara: Yeah.
>> [inaudible] But the old Packard
Building, I worked there the summer
of '65 as a college student.
The defense department was there.
I worked with the defense
department, and I remember going
from one building to
another building,
and going through the
abandoned parts
of the car company,
and how scary it was.
You would go through
there, and you'd see chassis
and engines just laying around,
and I would always be looking
for the rats to come out.
But it's completely
gone now, like you said.
Someone has said they're going
to investigate and rebuild it.
But I don't know if that's
really going to happen.
>> Camilo Vergara: Yeah, no.
There were raves at one time.
You know, they had music inside.
The sort of interesting thing
is that one thing from Detroit
and from the rest of the country
from the very poor areas is
that what survives and thrives is
the music that's created there.
The visuals, not, you know.
It's like, what's inside the
storefront churches that disappears,
but, you know, we all know
the Supremes, and Motown,
and techno music, and so on.
Go ahead.
>> When you started taking photos in
Detroit, did you know you were going
to keep coming back and documenting,
or did that happen later?
Like, when did you decide
these would become series?
>> Camilo Vergara: Well, you know,
it's partly I think, you know,
with reference to the ending,
is just that the first picture
that I take just tries
to be a complete picture
of whatever's in front of me.
And then, you know, the picture
is like a question, you know.
What's going to happen
to this place?
So, you know, I feel like
I have to go, you know.
So, I mean, you kind of arrange your
finances and you figure, you know,
who is going to put me up?
Is somebody going to lend me a car?
Who is going to, you
know, what I'm going
to eat, and that sort of thing.
And then you figure you have
enough money, so you go back.
And, you know, that's kind
of my way, and I'm very, see,
I haven't been able to do
Cleveland because, basically,
there was no base that I
could stay in Cleveland.
There was no place.
I would have loved to have
done Cleveland or, you know,
some of the cities of the South.
But that's the idea.
I mean, and I think I've had very
good luck with American historians
and people interested
in American culture,
and architecture, and so on.
I've had lousy luck with people who
do art photography and want to show,
you know, great, their, you
know, moment [phonetic],
and the National Gallery, and
all those places, you know.
I've had a couple of places --
the Getty or some other places
have had a few pictures.
So it's like a fragmented.
It's a divided approach to
photography that if you wanted
to make it as a photographer,
you know,
all the stuff I'm telling
you is completely irrelevant.
Why do you want to put for your
photograph in the first place?
Why you want to give us the year?
Why do you want to tell us
something about the evolution
and the history of the place?
Just show us a great picture, you
know, that, an amazing picture.
>> Mari Nakahara: Okay,
well, thank you very much.
>> Camilo Vergara: Okay.
>> Mari Nakahara: And at the end,
that you may want to see more
of Camilo's pictures, and if you can
actually show it, we have a Prints
and Photographs Division online
catalog, and especially for the WTC,
we have a kind of sequence
for the same [inaudible]
upload a little bit, quickly.
So if you go to the LOC.gov/pictures
and then do the search,
and then you can see all of
these World Trade Center series
by location.
So please play around
and you will see more
and more pictures of the Camilo.
[laughs] Great, cheers.
And thank you for coming
to this lecture,
and books are available outside of
this building and in the hallway.
Camilo is ready to sign
on the book for you.
So thank you again, and thank you.
>> Camilo Vergara: Thank you.
>> Mari Nakahara: Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.